the Joe Rogan experience I want an elk
you do we don't invite me sorry
listen you don't do it anymore you don't
really do it dude I'm dead I I'm gay my
sweetie I love you yeah there's the
level between doing what we did where
you have a rifle yeah do oh no you're
doing BOSU in both it's so much work you
get to the point where you can do it
efficiently Oh cuz you're doing badly
yes though I show up with a gun you can
definitely do that if the place is if
it's legal to have a good you know the
place for that for you would be Hawaii
really yes lanai access dear you and I
have to shoot them you and I need to go
to my friend's property in New Zealand
and sure but the they probably need to
shoot those to New Zealand doesn't they
do they don't have any he's got fire
drivers beaches Candida Branson wolves
bring some wolves to New Zealand dude
what could go wrong his jet skis with
[ __ ] orcas he sends me video he's on
his jet ski on his private beach he goes
yeah orcas under him the first family
that gets eaten inside their tent by
wolves and that can happen and has
happened in history folks the first
family that that ever happens to we're
all gonna have a big wake-up call as to
what a wolf is it's not that I don't
love wolves I do love wolves and I went
to that wolf connection that rescue out
in in the Senate the city of palmdale I
went to it really recently with for
Escalante and is you seems amazing yeah
hung out with them coolest [ __ ] but it's
pure wolves are hybrids most of them are
hybrids um one of them was about as
close to a pure wolf as you can get you
couldn't do a goddamn thing with them
this guy said that one time he
admonished him for a food fight and he
was incorrect and the dope the wolf
hasn't spoken to him since why three
years ago the wolves like [ __ ] you he
used to be able to pet him put him on
walk take him out now the wolf won't let
him anywhere near him really decide the
guy was a [ __ ] three years ago that male
male wolves will challenge you and you
know certain animals like camels camels
if they like you you're good if they
don't like you
they'll piss on you they'll spit on you
whoa and they will grab you and bite you
and throw
they pick you up by your neck with their
teeth I've seen that don't [ __ ] around
with Cairo I saw a guy trying to kill a
camel he was trying to you know there's
like a certain way they killed camels
for some religious eat you you can eat
but in a certain way they kill him you
know with a knife they slightly sliced
her throat right and he was doing that
and this camel was not having it and he
grabs him by the back of the neck his
[ __ ] whips him through the air you
realize how strong a camel is yeah it
bites your neck you're a 150-pound man
you're going flying you're gonna find it
Chuck you just Chuck you like you throw
a housecat board a mate camel he said it
was really good all right yeah but it
was it like delicious was it tastes like
it's like goat you know I guess a lot of
times in in Saudi Arabia you need a
camel with a huge feast you'd put a goat
inside the camel Wow oh here's one these
guys trying to slice yeah this is
another one okay yeah right there look
at that guy boom son if that thing
picked him up by his head he got his
whole head in there look at that guy
that's his whole head oh my god that
wasn't just a neck that thing grabbed
his whole head he's gotta be [ __ ] up
bro you might realized yeah no he's
moving thank God look at that
God yeah I just grabbed his whole house
it picked him up by his head yeah dude
that could easily break your neck
especially thing didn't let go what if
it shook them yeah you just held on to
the house shove them a bunch of times
that thing has mean [ __ ] yeah don't [ __ ]
with camels yeah so it's like a goat
it's a lot of meat it's a lot of meat
how many people ate that Ken I don't
member I was kid by the way I was 14 13
I ate it so I'm saying go to eat with
their hands right you would your right
hand yes you're right and you watch your
ass with your left hand dirty never give
anybody you left so [ __ ] caught stealing
traditionally I'm sorry they would cut
off your last one wait you have to in
the crab you'd be the last one to eat oh
my would you have what was left over oh
my god yeah what do you do then just
kill the guy like why do you want to
live like this now you live with one
hand it's fine figure it out
[Applause]